it is time to play dying light to
everybody um obviously i have already
played a little bit of this game never
the beginning though um i did get to
play at a preview event in november
and um i'm excited to jump into what the
start is because i don't actually know
how the story starts out they just gave
us like a little bit of context um as
mentioned in my preview i did have a
fair amount of bugs
um
some that were especially frustrating
like getting stuck while trying to run
and then having zombies kill me be the
only way out or whatever so hopefully uh
this version is a little bit better um i
believe i am playing
here we go version 1.0.2 here on normal
and uh
jump into it
i
have been excited about this game for
ages and i feel like the preview build
like maybe took me down a little bit
like
i kind of uh felt like some of the stuff
that i was hoping would be in the game
was not necessarily there but i'm still
super into it i really loved the
the combat and i felt like the world
building was really cool so
yeah i'm still uh
stoked to jump in
i'd love to start with here we go okay
20 36.
also i'm sorry if you can hear the
person my neighbor
who is just like
leaf blowing or something right now
about that
they have to start white right when you
record every time
oh that's pretty
[Applause]
i'm gonna jump straight into gameplay i
wasn't expecting that look at it damn
okay
you still got it you know this game used
to be more fun
and you used to be younger i ain't
dumber
what matters is you steal just as fast
because a slope yeah a dead pilgrim yeah
i know i know i would love to climb that
mountain
i don't think they'll let me but can you
imagine
[Music]
that
that do be looking good
it's nice to play it on my own pc to see
you know what it'll look like for me i
um i remember if i said this in the
preview one thing
that i felt from the preview
was that i didn't think the game looked
as nice as it looked in trailers
but i mean this is very pretty vista
um okay uh tutorial of course yes
obviously i'm playing on pc
oh
that was strange
okay it might have just been my monitor
everything just went black for a second
i don't know if that'll show up in the
captcha
might it might have been on my end
oh
yeah i feel like you can jump like extra
far uh which is kind of nice [ __ ] man
you're still
oh what
climb to the ledge okay
um
glad he said i'm still strong that's
very nice i'm gonna jump over here that
seems like a big jump man that seems
like a long way to jump
all right i am still strong
thanks
it's good to see you spike how long has
it been
far too long but don't get all mushy on
me now come i want to show you something
i mentioned this in the previous world
but um where are we going
you'll see
one of the things that i like the most
about it that i didn't expect
and you're still alive um
was that i found the side characters to
all be like pretty interesting like but
i'm [ __ ] awesome like fallout's kind
of interesting yeah right right
seriously it was pretty i wish i had as
much energy as you
got a new lead on jane
the trail went cold after new paris
which route you take through baynes or
gary
that baines what a [ __ ] some five
rickety huts left and a ramshackle fence
look at that a beehive full of honey
can't let an opportunity like this go to
waste i like the way he talks
opportunity look around if we're lucky
there's chamomile growing here too
camomile
who what
a big fan of pronunciation so
um okay
seems like a bad idea but all right
that's fine okay that's fine
uh we're looking for chamomile
chamomile
f
more
chamomile
i believe you can upgrade the survivor
sense too i remember correctly
i'll take more honey oops sorry guys
sorry followers just pressed an e
instead of an f there sorry about it uh
there's a lot of honey i don't know what
i'm gonna use it for but i'll take it
uh
more chamomile my friend
you know what chamomile looks like right
well if you tested my patience friend
i've actually never seen chamomile in
the wild i don't that seems like uh
well okay in this world maybe it would
make sense but generally speaking not
that reasonable of an assumption i'm
probably missing it i bet you it's come
up and i'm just not seeing it can be a
problem with having a very large screen
markup marker marker
what happens if i do if i do that if i
do that
camera mile is that you my friend or is
that no that's just some light
come on come on i feel like i'm looking
around too
frantically
how am i not [ __ ] seeing it
okay maybe up here
i keep trying to kick
just
gonna kick a plant
cool
do you remember that old herbalist we
helped escort to her village
yes oh yeah the one that had that saying
uh
remember chamomile and honey are gifts
that keep giving
combine them and lucky sweet you just
might go on living
you've received your first blueprint
blueprints uh plans that allow you to
create accessories consumables and
weapons modifications using various
craft parts scavenged during exploration
cool
this is where you store all of the craft
parts you collect read the craft part
description to see how they use and
where you can find them i don't actually
do a lot of crafting uh hold over the
medicine blueprint to craft it this is
pretty similar to the first game if i
remember correctly
i will craft as much as i can i need
more camo mile
come on we almost there do americans say
chamomile is that what it is
compelling
naturally i'm already very invested in
the story because of this
pronunciation dispute
this is it come on
i'm here my friend let's go
all right sneak
this is cool very lost of us vibes
i guess you could say that about any
apocalypse they're really in a video
game
wow
somebody had a nice crib yeah
this is actually making me think of um
that black mirror episode the one with
the robots locked i'll try to get
through here you check the other side
all righty my friend check in the other
side
nope uh c to crouch makes sense what did
i just press actually i'd like to figure
out how i did that how did i
oh i will rant a little bit okay see
it feels like there's gonna be zombies
in here
it just feels like
like this is probably zombie vibes
maybe not
[Music]
just a crate just a crate
oh
the way it grabbed the camera made me
nervous
jump scare
okay [ __ ] up not quite i'm not scared
everything all right
somebody's walking yeah just rats how'd
you get in i think it's time we parted
ways
why
i'm starting to worry about you and you
know i sang you're starting to worry
about someone it means it's time to go
what
okay i
guess but i we still have so many
discussions to be had about
how we pronounce chamomile
um that's odd okay strange but all right
i liked him is he gonna like try and
kill me i don't that was odd i'm unsure
why that happened
um all right
i feel like i had this issue with the um
it's like i unless i'm doing that wrong
with the with the preview build where
sometimes i would press f and things
just wouldn't just wouldn't f
but it's possible that i need to do
something else
give you a quick give you a nice kick
just kick you out no
okay where else
that is
oh first aid i'd love to see that
empty that's a shame
nothing in here
[Music]
the last spring party
but by then the gre would have long
since lost control of the virus
dan's like it's the end of the world
march 21st huh
that's not that far away
gonna have that party next year that'd
be great
five years later who remembers haran is
there any hope left a thousand people
trapped around oh that's cool nice
little easter egg there
so we never could interact aha there we
go
nothing here great love that i waited
for for that um i think that's
everything
in the immediate vicinity
buddy
is he gonna turn or something what are
you doing my friend
i don't love that either okay
i wonder how the wine tasted back then
what look at all these unused cigarettes
i feel like those are going to be and
the cigar
there's got to be worth money i mean
they're all bendy
but
you should i feel like you should take
those my friend
what what
what
what when did you get over that
i'm very unsettled by him
who do you voodoo
sounds familiar [ __ ]
[Music]
where does he keep going
so just stay put okay
and that's what they called art
roasted
absolutely [ __ ] wrecked it's gonna
take a while to recover where did you go
now
he's freaking me out man
maybe it's supposed to freak me out
i will take scraps thank you
i will take this backpack
thank you some rags love that for me
what does that mean oh it's a hiding
place
that's ominous
okay i guess he's just roaming and i'm
just freaking out about a man walking
not necessarily any cause for concern
people are allowed to walk
that's gonna be hiding as well probably
ah cool
[Music]
it's very dark
this is super pretty though
[Music]
[Music]
that's so dramatic
sorry dave goodbye
[Music]
that's heartbreaking is it that
oh [ __ ]
there's nothing like a party to
celebrate the end of the world
they died on their own terms i guess if
you're close to dying you're about to
get them turned into a zombie you just
keep it simple you know sorry dave
you check out the garden okay didn't he
okay
what
didn't he just said say it was time to
go out separate ways
what
what the [ __ ]
am i missing something
[Music]
what
did
[Music]
i
maybe
something played out of order or
um
i am missing something which i wouldn't
put past me because
it's easy to not
pay full attention to dialogue at the
start of something when you're not a zip
doing your exploring and [ __ ] but um i
could have sworn he said he was getting
a bad feeling about me and that we
should split up
i'm very confused
okay
oh
how did they die
people starve to death maybe
[Music]
yeah
that's pretty sad
sorry dave goodbye
[Music]
oh that's extra sad i mean this is
beautiful though like
you know
like you're dead but check your
privilege you know what i'm saying i
wish i wish
how much is this
in la
10 bill
10 whole billion probably not quite that
much but
when it gets over a million who even
knows how much money it is this you know
you guys you you might be dead but i i
say you lucked out this is [ __ ]
beautiful man what a gorgeous shot
i like the way that they juxtaposed
the beautiful real estate with the
sadness of everybody being dead
though it is
a little at odds with themselves because
they're so happy
like that and your book's not decomposed
what are you reading
sorry about that
and also
like this guy's just happening he's even
still playing music did they die all of
a sudden was this a bomb blast
[Music]
or did they like kill themselves out
here did they commit that they were
gonna die and they wanted to just be
together how did they die
because i don't feel like starving to
death
looks like this
we're in the quest area maybe we'll find
out maybe that's the whole point
they party too hard you have a party so
hard that you and your homies stand up
dead oh that's sad
missing half your body
man how pretty
witches
welcome to the lost potty okay they did
right they killed themselves
okay i respect it i respect it
that's a real picture
dearest mary
i'm sorry i ran from you
they say that once the virus makes you
turn
you're gone forever
fire's time that can't be true
i know you're still in there
underneath all that pain and disease
i'm coming to join you okay yeah no more
running my suicide body that is pretty
[ __ ] up hey
come here check this out i thought you
wanted to
didn't you say
that had to be a line that played at the
wrong place it had to be the snow i'm
what
yeah this is pretty messed up they all
just
killed themselves i guess
i don't know i respect it
not a not a bad place to go
um okay i'm gonna go upstairs
[Music]
let's party indeed
in the
suppose
house
show me staircase
i've been here
oh is this where i came from it is
uh staircase
[Music]
damn dude beautiful house
beautiful house
what
oh i'm clipped
just clipped on a little bit of a stair
happens to the best place maybe i
clipped on the on the painting
i think that's probably what it is
nope gotta jump over that okay
just doing some bug fixes for the tech
land in real time hope they watch this
we'll clip on that painting
um
okay
sit down buddy
for you
a gift a gift from the heavens to be
more accurate i've just found it by the
owner's dead body
may it be more used to you
thanks
here
it's gone flat
look at you and your sophisticated
palette what did you expect
chump what did you think was gonna
happen the end of the world could be so
peaceful it's beautiful
yeah at least until night falls true
i wish crane could have seen this who
doesn't matter
[Music]
i'll track down that guy for you
[Music]
i think that my webcam may be slightly
out of sync i need to fix that um
what guy
what what guy
quit pretending you became a pilgrim to
track that [ __ ] down waltz i found
someone who knows him
hey what and you're only telling me now
when i tossed your beer thought you
guessed right away we're celebrating
it's
strange the guy's in villadore
supposedly he knows something about
waltz
villadore
i saw him that close huh
okay i got a favor to ask you
you deliver this to gary it's on your
way
people don't like pilgrims there but but
they pay well
and where do people like pilgrims harsh
well they're afraid of us right everyone
does their best to survive
maybe when something needs to be
transported through the hordes of
infected and suddenly they're knocking
on our doors
all right but you owe me one
is this accent changed oh not just this
a different man
so what about that guy
well i talked to him over the radio
he didn't tell me his name
sounds like he's got something to hide
see that antenna on the hill
that'll help you contact the informant
he'll be listening for you at dawn on a
frequency of
140.200 megahertz
totally hear from you soon
okay
what does he want in return
didn't say
but he didn't sound like the kind of guy
who does things for free
i don't think that kind of guy exists
what what about me
you're an old fart who likes racing me
and makes me ask around about his crazy
girlfriend
hey hey hey she's not crazy
jane's just maybe
well a little hot-headed
and she's always getting herself into
trouble
but if you could get a load of her
all right still too early in the evening
for that sort of time eyes i was going
to say aye
wow
steely
huge never heard anyone get so worked up
about gray eyes
because you don't know [ __ ] about the
world let alone damn called out yeah
you're probably right
i'm telling you i'll finally find jane
we'll set up a house
we're going to live there no one's going
to drive us out
and i'll stop wondering like a [ __ ]
i'll drink to that
those are open right that's super gross
what's his deal is he family no
not at all
then why are you looking for him
will you tell me sometime
yeah yeah one day i am so sure spike's
gonna die my time's up so when will i
see you again huh in another two years
maybe
take care man
i hope you find that waltz guy or
whoever you're looking
for thank you and remember
140.200 megahertz at dawn the guy's
waiting for you
um i've actually decided to leave it
there uh time just kind of got away from
me so i feel like i shouldn't record too
much more seems like a good part to like
show you guys the opening right before
getting into the first uh
significant combat encounter sort of
i'll be streaming the game later tonight
if you want to uh see more of it and
probably throughout the week um so i
will see you guys on twitch thank you
for watching the first 30-ish minutes of
the game i think is what this
came out to
and i will see you guys next time bye